[Música]
[Aplausos]
gastas ahorrar y ganas
cuando yo era una niña allá por los 60
70 del siglo pasado
cuando ingresadas a la escuela
entregaban una libreta como ésta una
libreta de ahorros
ahorrar es la base de la fortuna
ella pegaba más prolijamente estampillas
que tenían valor monetario
las comprábamos en la escuela con las
monedas que nuestros padres daban para
gastar en el recreo junto con las
galletitas manos
y se llevan acumulando unas tras otras
en busca de nuestros sueños
distribuya con métodos sus ingresos
no malgaste a orden nos decían la caja
nacional de ahorro postal el estado
nacional su vida de su dinero
con la esperanza de que nuestros
proyectos pegábamos las estampillas los
proyectos de un niño en este caso de una
niña
la
la relación de vinilo de joan manuel
serrat
entonces y hambre
tranqui
el tiempo transcurre las estampillas se
acumulaban
es el momento de cambiarlas
hacemos
cuando trancón el dinero las estampillas
[Música]
no era el hilo
mientras miraba las estampillas
la política económica
cambio la denominación de la moneda
los pesos se transformaron el peso ley
18.188
y el dinero obtenido de mis ahorros no
alcanzaban ni para un disco simple
fue mi primer gran desilusión y cómodo
en la borró by la base de la fortuna
increpaba a mi familia
cielo la base de la fortuna de la
fortuna de quién
pregunta
en
el cambio de valor
como el dinero pierde valor
los precios aumentan el dinero a un
villarreal
pero ustedes me dijeron
[Música]
tenía que obra
ustedes ahora
y se compra cosas
[Música]
ahorrando
hasta el momento servía en un silencio
de radio
pero no sabe mucho
mi familia que como muchas familias de
nuestro país desciende de los barcos
cuando hablaba de
cuestiones cotidianas negocios primero
hablaban en dinero
y cuando hablaban de amor no
hablaban
[Música]
y el dinero
sobre él
debe ser la moneda del estado de israel
y rápidamente me di cuenta que eran
dólares
los dólares son de los estados unidos
en 2
como ser viviendo en alguien
para comprar una moneda que no es real
años antes digital pero no había dicho
que ha visto un dólar
no era tan común hablar
los dólares conseguían en las escasas
casas de cambio que estaban en capital
federal no en el conurbano
obtenían dólares y viajaba
no eran muchas las personas que podían
bien
pero como siempre fui bastante cabeza
alta
ahorraremos en dólares
sobre peso para dárselas de mi familia
que era el proveedor de él
mis primeros diez dólares
fueron obtenidos después de terminar
estoicamente de la escuela a mi casa
después de la clase de educación digital
sin haber almorzado
si es blanca pero con diez dólares
ya era toda una original
mira
es bastante complicado por
contra lo que querían de verdad
o sea nuevamente que recorriéramos de mi
familia que vaya a venderle dólares para
obtener un piso que me permita comprar
complejo no
personales
compraban dólares
las casas de cambio empezaban a crecer
también en el conurbano en el s
las personas se relacionaban con el
dólar
es el dólar
un indicador de ser un buen artista
él
un refugio de tormentas
la trinchera de canarismos
probablemente cuanto de ansiedades
pero sobre todo un chupete
saben que cada argentino de acuerdo a
las estadísticas de funk mostrado
tiene dos mil dólares
los bolsillos son los que alguien
y además
las ventas en la casa de cambio merecen
los 100 dólares
se compran diez veces de treinta y
cuarenta el menudeo
aunque
compradores
verdad
enterrar la lata en el fondo
puede dar
otra opción es la caja de seguridad
encontrada en la pared
no suena
los bancos
la voz de mi abuelo retumba bancos y
banqueros se quedan con tu dinero
y casi el corralón
comprando más pueden verlos guardarlos
resulta muy complicado
ya esta altura había ingresado en la
universidad obviamente en la carrera de
economía como no podía ser de otra
manera
qué
para que ahorramos
a ramón para ganar
carta no es todo
consumir
bueno
a honrar que postergar consumo me dijo
una vez un profesor en la universidad
consulta y malo porque se demoniza
cuando vas a un comercio
y comprar lo que necesitas
le pagas al mente
el comerciante en cada una su dinero le
paga a los empleados
el proveedor para reponer la mercancía
pero el productor 11 marines
los trabajadores tienen más empleos
luego está el crear actividad económica
de pronto
una frívola y la sola persona
se transforma en un constructor un
constructor de que estar en general un
promotor del desarrollo local
no suena mucho mejor que si me voy a
crear actividad económica
ingresando esto
o alienta
vida
cuanto más
o llamar esta vecina que vende por
catálogo estas cremas y perfumes
estándares
o ir a este comercio para reponer el
acolchado de las cortinas los manteles
de pronto no hay contribuir al bienestar
general
no suena científico
o por lo menos no les disminuye la culpa
bueno
hay que crear actividad económica
muy bueno
creo que cuando salgo me voy a crear
actividades económicas con esa cartera y
esos zapatos que viene el shopping
que me está en la mañana
bueno
las mejores cosas de la vida no se
compran y se ven
hay cosas que no se quieren con dinero
- la comida diría mi abuela
[Aplausos]
[Música]
farfán way